a hugely controversial decision has been
made by youtube
owned by google of course that they will
be straight up removing
any videos which claim that donald trump
lost the election because of so-called
voter fraud which doesn't exist
utah you youtube not utah youtube
is essentially saying joe biden won the
2020 election that's a historical
fact at this point and claims to the
contrary
will fall under the umbrella of
misleading videos
which are and can be restricted on
youtube youtube explains
now that enough states have certified
their elections
such that in total joe biden has 270
electoral votes
they will remove content that quote
misleads people by alleging that
widespread fraud or errors
change the outcome of the 2020
presidential election now they're not
going to go and do this retroactively so
if you uploaded videos before yesterday
saying
trump won because of voter fraud those
will be allowed to stay up
this is a decision that will go forward
from yesterday
youtube explaining the decision in a
series of tweets let's take a look
youtube saying our goal this election
was to connect people to authoritative
info
limit harmful misinformation and remove
violative content
subsequently authoritative news was
widely watched and recommended
and since september we removed more than
8 000 channels for violating our
policies
yesterday was the safe harbor deadline
now that enough states certified their
presidential election results
we'll remove any content published today
or anytime after
that alleges widespread fraud or errors
changed the 2020 u.s presidential
outcome now
that's there's a couple interesting
things there number one
it sounds like they're saying if you are
reporting about an individual instance
of of a clerical error or or fraud or
whatever
that will be allowed but big picture
saying trump really won but because a
voter fraud biden got it that's what
wouldn't be allowed
and the justification they're giving is
that joe biden's win
is now simple empirical undeniable fact
youtube going on to explain quote we'll
also update today
our election results info panel which
already surfaced under 200 000 vids
and was shown more than 4.5 billion
times
uh it'll note the u.s presidential res
results are certified and linked to the
2020 electoral college results page by
the office of the federal register
lastly saying there's always more to do
striking the balance between openness
and responsibility
is one of our toughest challenges we're
continuing to make improvements
and we'll apply our learnings from this
election globally
i'm actually unsure about the the
long-term effect of this policy and i'll
explain
in the sense that i think youtube might
make life difficult
for themselves with this decision so i
am 100
in agreement that this is completely
within youtube's rights as a business
i'm taking no issue with that whatsoever
youtube is doing nothing illegal here
period i think the implementation of
this is complex
because of the doors that it opens
fact-checking boxes for election content
with the results that say joe biden won
and it's been certified by states
i'm with it 100 even demonetization of
misleading videos which are effectively
conspiracy theories
i would even be okay with that flagging
content
like twitter does as disinformation or
disputed
often when trump tweets i won absolutely
fine
but the complexity is they allow
flat earth content they allow all sorts
of other conspiracy content that is
factually wrong
so now they have to make a distinction
about
what is factually wrong and justifies
removal and here they're saying broad
claims about election fraud
leading to joe biden falsely winning
that has passed a threshold
where it's not a flag it's not sorry i
hit my mic i'm getting so excited
it's not just a flag it's not just
demonetization it's removal now
to be completely clear the trump
actually won stuff
is completely corrosive to democracy
i've been clear and consistent on this
i'm just wondering about the enforcement
of this i might even like where
this goes in the sense that it might
push some of the looney right wing
voices to abandon youtube altogether
and go start their own thing that's
great stop the spread of disinformation
but i do think youtube is opening
themselves up to an
absolute storm of insanity as a result
this is not a censorship issue to me
biden won period youtube can do this
legally 110
but i think the enforcement is going to
be problematic and and the other thing
that i find interesting is
the right wingers are going nuts about
this and
clearly youtube made the calculation i
mean youtube knew
that this was going to be an s storm
when they do it
they calculated stopping the election
conspiracy theories
is worth it to them in exchange
for the criticism that is raining down
upon them from the right
for this decision so uh my concern is
more about implementation and the
precedent that it sets
but we will see ultimately how this
turns out i would love to hear
your thoughts about this decision by
youtube i'm on twitter at d
pacman one of our sponsors today is
magic spoon the reason i'm such a fan of
magic spoon is they allow me to enjoy
the delicious breakfast cereals i loved
as a kid
without all the sugar and without the
unhealthy ingredients because magic
spoon makes breakfast cereal
that you really can't tell apart from
those tasty sugary
cereals that we all know but each
serving of magic spoon has no sugar
three net carbs and 11 grams of protein
so it's perfect for someone on a low
carb
keto diet just anybody trying to eat
healthier and cut back on the sugar
you can choose from cocoa frosted fruity
cinnamon blueberry or peanut butter they
all taste amazing
and magic spoon now lets you create your
own customized variety pack
with the flavors you choose they really
do stand by their product and will
refund 100 percent of your money if you
don't love it
no questions asked go to magicspoon.com
pacman to build your own custom variety
box today
make sure to use promo code pacman to
get free shipping
the link is right underneath this video